et nous passons à la chronique culture
la page culture du mercredi dans le 78
Aurélia et oui donc ce soir nous
recevons donc trois représentants de
lieu d'animation dédiés aux enfants et
aux familles donc Bruno gcel bonsoir
donc vous êtes responsable de la
communication pour les fermes de
Gal Marianne edvir bonsoir vous êtes
également responsable communication et
marketing pour France Miniature et enfin
leurvallette vous êtes animatrice pour
le patrimoine enfin pour le patrimoine
et l'architecture pour le musée de la
ville de saintquanttin Yveline bonsoir
bonsoir alors nous allons partir déjà du
côté de la ferme et bien écoutez Bruno
quelles sont les animations que vous
proposez cette semaine donc cette
semaine on va proposer plein
d'animations pour les enfants on va leur
apprendre par exemple à à fabriquer du
beurre en partant de la crème on va leur
apprendre à fabriquer des nourrissoires
pour les oiseaux qui vont commencer à à
prendre vie dans le jardin avec le
printemps qui arrive on va leur faire
faire du papier recyclé donc plein
d'ateliers de de ce type là encore sur
la fin de cette semaine d'accord donc ça
ce sont les ateliers que vous appelez
classiques parce qu'ils sont aussi
présentés tout au long de l'année et
notamment je crois l'atelier patapin
exactement l'atelier patapin est un des
ateliers phar à la ferme de Gal et oui
et justement nous sommes allés
rencontrer les enfants qui ont assisté à
cet atelier hier regardez la recette est
déjà bien maîtrisée
qui ne pétit bon pain ne mange il s'agit
bien là d'une expérience à laquelle on
participer les enfants de l'atelier pâte
à pain de la ferme de Gal à saint-ciier
l'école pendant 45 minutes il découvre
les ingrédients nécessaires à la
fabrication du pain puis mett en
pratique la recette nos petits apprentis
boulongers ont du pain sur la planche au
programme moudre le blé pétrir et
façonner la pâte le but du jeu c'est
vraiment de chaque enfant et compris les
ingrédients de la pâte à pain et d'avoir
à la fin chacun sa pâte et puis ça sera
à faire cuire à la maison après parce
qu'il faut 2 heures du coup pour que la
pâte lève bien les explications de
l'animatrice sont claires et à la portée
des enfants la recette semble déjà être
bien maîtrisée la levure du sel du la
farine et de l'eau cet atelier pratique
laisse ici au plus jeunes le temps et la
liberté d'action nécessaire à
l'apprentissage de la cuisine qui n'est
pas toujours chose évidente à la maison
je trouve que c'est assez ludique en
plus ils peuvent voir les animaux avant
de faire l'atelier ils ont appris des
choses en faisant l'atelier des choses
qui font pas forcément à l'école et qui
font pas forcément avec nous ce qu'on a
pas le temps donc du coup je trouve ça
assez assez sympa pas cher et pas loin
trois ateliers patapin sont proposés
chaque jour pendant les vacances
scolaires sans oublier les classiques de
la ferme ouverte et les activités
thématique et Bruno ganal dites-nous
également qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez
comme anation pour la deè semaine donc
la Dee semaine on va avoir plein
d'ateliers thématiques autour des
oiseaux organisés en collaboration avec
le Corif le centre d'ornitologie
d'Île-de- France alors les rapasses hein
particulièrement ou il va y avoir
pendant 3 jours lundi mardi mercredi des
ateliers pour faire découvrir les
rapaces nocturnes nos enfants et pour
leur faire découvrir ces oiseaux qu'on a
pas l'occasion de voir souvent mais
qu'on peut entendre notamment à partir
du printemps et durant l'été on entend
les les chouettes on va faire dépioter
aux enfants ce qu'on appelle pelotes de
réjaction c'estàd quand ces rapaces sont
des oiseaux qui vont manger notamment
des petits rongeurs des petites souris
des petits mulot mus un atelier pratique
scientifique tout à fait tout à fait
puisque c'est chouette une fois qu'elles
ont mangé ces ces oiseaux ces ces petits
rongeurs elles vont digérer les
rongeures et puis elles vont recracher
les boules de poil et d'os qui ne sont
pas digéré par comme ça est-ce que les
parents vont être séduits je ne sais pas
j'ai une question à vous poser vous
concurrencez un petit peu l'espace
rembouillé là en présentant les rapaces
l'espace rembouillé qui a fait son fond
de commerce de présenter justement les
les l'espace rembouillé on voit les les
oiseaux en en vrai on on les on les voit
physiquement nous de notre côté
l'objectif est pas de de voir les
oiseaux mais de sensibiliser les les
enfants à ces oiseaux qu'on qui vont
entendre le long de l'année et on veut
leur leur montrer de quoi se nourrissent
ces oiseaux et donc en dépiotant ces ces
petites pelotes de réjection ils vont
pouvoir on y revient ils vont pouvoir
reconstituer le le squelette des souris
et et donc voir concrètement que que
c'est écoutez je je demande à voir le
succès que vous aurez sur cet atelier on
viendra voir comment réagissent les les
enfants donc ça c'est le lundi mardi
mercredi et le jeudi vous organisez
également un jeu plateau du type jeu de
loi et là qui retracerait la migration
de ces essayer de faire comprendre aux
enfants comment est-ce que les oiseaux
assurent leur migration pourquoi est-ce
que les oiseaux partent à l'automne et
et l'hiver de de notre région pour
partir soit dans le sud de la France
soit encore plus au sud hein sur
d'autres continents comment est-ce
qu'ils font pour venir et et quels sont
les dangers auxquels ils sont confrontés
d'accord alors vous avez également une
autre programmation un petit peu plus
tardive là à l'occasion de de pâqu
racontez-nous quelles seront ces
animations il y aura la traditionnelle
chasse aux ufs fête des œufs hein à Gali
qui se fait maintenant depuis plus de 15
ans ou le dimanche de pâqu donc qui
tombe le 31 mars cette année on va
accueillir les familles qui vont venir
chercher les œufs dans les champ de la
ferme donc les enfants de 3 à 12 ans
vont participer à cette chasse aux œufs
et puis pour toutes la famille ces
enfants-l puis les accompagnants ils
vont pouvoir prendre part à plein
d'ateliers il y a de la tonte de mouton
il y a de la fabrication de d'atelierers
créatif avec la laine il y aura de la
dégustation de chocolat il y aura plein
plein d'ateliers à c'est l'arrivée du
printemps donc je crois qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup de naissance effectivement il y
a les premières naissances qui ont eu
lieu à la à la ferme là les premiers
chevux les premiers agneaux et puis il y
aura des bien évidemment des poussins
puisque à PCT traditionnellement il y a
l'arrivée des premiers poussins d'accord
quel bilan vous pouvez faire de la
premièrees semaines un petit peu
d'exploitation sur les vacances et bien
écoutez les les les familles ont ont
répondu ont répondu présentes euh et il
y a pas mal de de familles qui viennent
non pas parents enfant mais plutôt
grands-parents grands-parents enfant
donc c'est aussi intergénérationnel et
et très très sympathique très bien merci
beaucoup merci alors donc on rappelle
euh donc là encore jeudi et vendredi
vous avez des animations spécifiques
donc cette semaine parce qu'on l'a pas
évoqué rapidement mais jeudi donc c'est
la création verte hein c'est donc la
confection d'une PL d'une palette pardon
de couleur naturelle et puis les
empreintes florales en argile plus les
ateliers classiques qu'on retrouve toute
l'année pâte à pain recyclage du papier
et cetera ok très bien et ben écoutez
euh nous allons passer maintenant faire
une petite
pause ateliers qui sont proposés on
s'intéressera au musée de la ville on
s'intéressera aussi à France Miniature
auparavant le cinéma nous sommes
mercredi chaque mercredi et l di mooine
ser ront à la sortie des salles pour
vous demander vos premières réactions et
les conseils des spectateurs aux
spectateurs c'est très bien beaucoup
d'action et il y a rien à redire tout
est bien surtout la 3D qui fait la
différence super bien comme film super
bien super bien fait plein d'action j'ai
dé adoré comme film ben c'était super
sympa mignon pierre Ninet est juste
incroyable voilà c'était c'était
agréable à regarder quoi une excellente
comédie et des beau comédiens tout à
fait original un super moment non film
très agréable il joue super bien très
très bien c'est une petite comédie
sentimentale sympa
voilàpa c'est pas le film de l'année
mais il y a des bons dialogues c'est
c'est agréable c'est bien et puis des
bons acteurs j'ai trouvé que c'était un
film très bien avec beaucoup d'humour
enfin voilà c'était c'était sympa
effrayant c'est une vision un peu
comment dire effrayante effrayante de de
la réalité d'aujourd'hui si les les plus
jeunes voilà ont voir ce genre de film
j'espère que ils comprendop le message
qu'il y a derrière genre faut pas mener
une vie comme ça j'ai j'ai adoré les
l'image la photographie est génial le
travail des couleurs j'ai vraiment été
fan je je m'attendais pas trop à
grand-chose sur le scénario bon je suis
quand même content c pas trop classique
et enfin ouais c'était une bonne
découverte pas le film du siècle mais je
suis content de l'avoir vu quand
même et puisque l'on parle de cinéma
cette information qui concerne le ciné7
à hencour le cinéma devait rouvrir
aujourd'hui le 6 mars après un an et
demi de retard dans les travaux mais
nouveau retard la commission de sécurité
n'a pas pu se présenter pas de raison
officielle avancé et surtout pas de
nouvelle date pour une nouvelle
validation avant l'ouverture au public
le directeur Luc bean se dit très déçu
plus d'informations à suivre dans nos
prochaines éditions et je vous rappelle
qu'au 1er avril l'agglomération de 5 ans
ne versera plus d'indimnité pour la
perte d'exploitation à ce cinéma les
coupur qui s'accumulent nous suivrons ce
dossier bien sûr de près comme on le
fait depuis plus de 2 ans 2 ans et demi
de travaux maintenant pour le cineset et
cette réouverture qui se fait toujours
attendre